[Música]
creciendo el año de 1995 como todos
ustedes saben méxico se sumergió en una
crisis económica muy profunda y en una
caída en su imagen debido a los
escándalos de corrupción esta crisis en
alguna medida y función mis decisiones y
el número que daría mi carrera
profesional
al mismo tiempo desde niña siempre me
dijeron que era buena en mapas mentales
por mi habilidad para relacionar
conceptos de una manera estructurada
al mismo tiempo me empezaron a llamar la
atención disciplinas como las políticas
públicas y el desarrollo económico y
soñé con especializarme en ellas para
utilizarlas como antídotos contra
cánceres como la desigualdad y la
injusticia
en 1995 un año crucial para méxico pero
también para el mundo
en ese año se lanzaba a la plataforma de
acción de beijing está la plataforma más
visionaria para empoderar a mujeres y
niñas de todo el mundo y que marcaría un
antes y un después para luchar contra la
desigualdad que tanto les afecta
esta es la plataforma más progresista en
favor de las mujeres y que se lanzaba en
el marco del 50 aniversario de las
naciones unidas en la ciudad de beijing
donde se reunieron representantes de más
de 89 países y más de 30.000 activistas
y donde se alcanzó un acuerdo histórico
en donde se concluyó que los derechos de
las mujeres también son derechos humanos
en 1995 también surgió una herramienta
novedosa para medir la corrupción
este es el índice de percepción de la
corrupción este índice es un parteaguas
por lo difícil que resulta medir la
corrupción debido a que es una actividad
que se realiza en secrecía y que
difícilmente los involucrados van a
compartir su experiencia
con todos estos sin precedentes
dejé mi ciudad natal mazatlán sinaloa
para irme a vivir a la ciudad de mexico
y hacer mis estudios universitarios de
economía y ciencia política
con toda la energía y con toda la
esperanza que me daba al ser tan joven
adquirir las herramientas analíticas
para luchar contra los problemas
sociales que tanto me interesaban
al terminar mis estudios decidí enfocar
mi carrera profesional en la
administración pública federal y desde
allí hacer una transformación dentro del
sistema con mis humildes conocimientos y
contribuir a hacer de méxico un país más
justo e igualitario
sin embargo en el año 2009 en una tarde
gélida de octubre era un día como
cualquier otro salí del trabajo y aborde
un taxi
mi instinto de supervivencia me decía
que algo no andaba bien mi corazón se
empezó a acelerar cuando otro carro nos
cerró el cruce
y los hombres me abordaron
estaba siendo secuestrada
y violentada física y verbalmente mis
secuestradores tomaron mis credenciales
y mis tarjetas de crédito con la amenaza
de que no se me ocurriera denunciar
porque estaban coludidos con la policía
de mi entonces delegación y le querían
por mí en caso de que se me ocurriera
hacerlo
este hecho tuvo un gran impacto en mi
salud mental y me hizo darme cuenta de
la falta de integridad de los
funcionarios que estaban ahí para
servirnos
lo que había vivido no solamente era un
secuestro sino un caso dentro de un
sistema de corrupción debido a que los
secuestradores estaban concluidos con la
policía y que me denuncia eslava
serviría de muy poco
este hecho me hizo sentir vulnerable y
sin poder
ahora yo formaba parte de las
estadísticas de las víctimas de
corrupción
ahora yo había vivido la corrupción y
era parte del sistema que perpetúa la
impunidad
este hecho me hizo darme cuenta que
había sido víctima de la injusticia
contra la que tanto soñaba luchar desde
niña
este hecho nado autos acontecimientos me
quisieron hacer brincar hacia lado
opuesto hacia la sociedad civil y desde
ahí exigir justicia transparencia y no
corrupción
decidí regresar a mi natal sinaloa y
desde ahí empezamos a hacer activismo
anti corrupción debido a que el tema de
la corrupción es muy amplio porque puede
haber corrupción en salud educación y
acceso a justicia por mencionar algunos
sectores
se me ocurrió utilizar mi habilidades
mapas mentales y relacionar como la
corrupción afectaba a la desigualdad
específicamente en cómo afectaba a las
mujeres
en ese momento estábamos viendo
colaborar con naciones unidas- mujeres y
vincular el tema de corrupción y género
parecía lo ideal
asimismo queríamos aprovechar la
vorágine de los movimientos feministas y
el impacto del movimiento mitú
al mismo tiempo estaban por cumplirse 25
años de la plataforma de acción de
beijing esta plataforma tan visionaria
para empoderar a las mujeres que habían
surgido en el año de 1995
todos ustedes pensarán que la corrupción
nos afecta a todos lo cual es verdad
pero mi punto era demostrar que existe
un impacto diferenciado de la corrupción
en las mujeres sobre los hombres uno de
mis principales obstáculos fue la falta
de datos en primer lugar no existen
encuestas ni datos desagregados de cómo
la corrupción nos afecta a las mujeres
toda la información que encontraba era
intuitiva y en segundo lugar esta
información también era muy académica y
abstracta difícil de entender para el
ciudadano
lo cual haría aún más difícil mi
objetivo de que las mujeres tomaran
conciencia de cómo les afecta la
corrupción por el hecho de ser mujeres y
que éstas que exigieron a las
autoridades crear las condiciones para
prevenir los efectos de la corrupción en
ellas
formación que me encontraba en la
corrupción afecta a las mujeres por el
fenómeno de la feminización de la
pobreza
esto quiere decir que de acuerdo a datos
del banco mundial las mujeres somos las
más pobres del mundo lo cual significa
que dependemos en mayor medida de acceso
a servicios públicos gratuitos como
educación salud y acceso a justicia si
existe corrupción en estos sectores las
mujeres no tendremos acceso a servicios
públicos de calidad y por lo tanto se
perpetuará la brecha de género
para poner este concepto en perspectiva
supongamos que tenemos a una mujer llama
al pita dado que el pita vive en
condiciones de pobreza depende de
acceder a servicios públicos como
educación salud y acceso a justicia
lupita quiere educarse y para ello se
acerca a la escuela pública de su
comunidad sin embargo al tratar de
inscribirse un funcionario de dicha
escuela le pide una mordida poima para
poder inscribirse
lupita no tiene dinero para pagarla
debido a que es la única escuela de su
vida
lupita se queda sin estudiar
lupita se embaraza y acude el hospital
público para medicamentos
sin embargo no los encuentra porque él
casi quiere su pueblo
robó los recursos destinados a
comprarlos
lupita acude el ministerio público y
quiere denunciar
y al tratar de escribir en la escuela un
funcionario trató de extorsionarlo sin
embargo el juez del ministerio público
este amigo de aquel funcionario que le
pidió la mordida point de esta manera lo
pita se queda sin acceso a servicios de
salud de educación y acceso a justicia
lo cual la deja sumergida en una trampa
de pobreza
de acuerdo a datos de la organización
transparencia internacional en el
reporte de como la corrupción nos afecta
a las mujeres en américa latina y en el
caribe y donde da a algunos de los pocos
datos desagregados que existen dicen que
las mujeres somos más proclives a pagar
sobornos por acceder a servicios de
salud lo cual es preocupante en una
crisis sanitaria tan brutal como la que
vivimos
este mismo reporte da otros datos igual
de preocupantes dice que las mujeres de
menores recursos son más proclives a
pagar sobornos para acceder a servicios
judiciales que las mujeres de mayores
recursos y sólo una de cada diez mujeres
que pagaron un soborno en los últimos 12
meses hizo una denuncia respectiva con
las autoridades
esto quiere decir que después de pagar
los sobornos las mujeres tenemos menos
ingresos disponibles para comprar un
libro para ahorrar o para crear un
negocio lo cual nos deja un círculo
vicioso de la pobreza
hasta ahora hemos hablado del dinero
como moneda de cambio para acceder a un
servicio público pero también existe
este tipo de soborno donde no es el
dinero la moneda de cambio sino es el
sexo
este tipo de soborno se llama extorsión
sexual y es un tipo de corrupción el
reporte time is now del banco mundial
reporta datos casos de su acción sexual
en colombia sudáfrica donde mujeres
rurales eran extorsionadas sexualmente a
cambio de recibir agua potable
este mismo reporte dice que en australia
la comisión de crimen de corrupción
encontró que un académico trató de
presionar a sus estudiantes para recibir
sexo a cambio de mejores calificaciones
utilizando toda su posición de poder
también de acuerdo a datos de varias
organizaciones humanitarias durante el
brote de ébola en el congo en el año
2019 mujeres locales fueron
extorsionadas sexualmente a cambio de
recibir la vacuna contra el ébola
bueno en perú se registró un caso de un
juez que trató de extorsionar
sexualmente a una mujer a cambio de
ayudarla a recibir la custodia de sus
hijos posteriormente este juez fue
castigado utilizando legislación de
corrupción sin embargo estos casos están
tan normalizados que no se visualizan
como corrupción
en méxico también las mujeres sufrimos
los efectos de la corrupción debido a
que existen delitos altamente sensibles
al género como la trata con fines de
explotación sexual y laboral
como lo explica a lydia cacho sus libros
los demonios del edén y esclavas del
poder donde denunció redes de trata con
fines de explotación sexual que afectó
principalmente a mujeres y niñas y donde
están involucrados políticos
funcionarios públicos y parte de la
élite empresarial del país
cabe mencionar que la trata con fines de
explotación sexual y laboral es un
crimen que implica grandes cadenas de
corrupción porque implica el traslado
encubrimiento y secuestro de mujeres y
donde están involucradas grandes
cantidades de personas que pueden ir
pueden ir siendo políticos funcionarios
públicos empresarios e incluso gente de
la sociedad civil
en méxico también hay un alto nivel de
feminicidios la impunidad ha incentivado
su proliferación un caso especial es el
caso de marisela escobedo una mujer de
chihuahua que hace una lucha incansable
para resolver el géminis sido de su hija
ruby
ella hace su propia investigación logra
la confesión del asesino sin embargo las
pruebas fueron desechadas por presunta
corrupción de los jueces todos sabemos
la historia final de marisela ella es
asesinada mientras hacía activismo
frente al palacio de gobierno en
chihuahua
pueden ver más de esto en el documental
las tres muertes de maribel a la
alcaldía de mi alta sobresalen los
homicidios de florian en establos usted
pec iv de la abuelita milicia en santa
ana tlacotenco
tres feminicidios en menos de tres días
en el mes de marzo en el mes de la mujer
por eso nosotros en país de áfrica nos
dimos cuenta que el problema de la
corrupción era un problema global por
eso decidimos llevar este tema a la
cumbre social civil del g20 en argentina
en el año 2018 esta fue la primera
cumbre del g20 donde se abordó el tema
de cómo la corrupción afectaba a las
mujeres y ahí junto con otras
organizaciones exigimos a las
autoridades y a los jefes de estado que
se crearan datos y encuestas desagregada
por género como la corrupción nos afecta
a las mujeres también les pedimos a los
jefes de estado que se tomaran acciones
contra la extorsión sexual
después de escuchar todo este tema
ustedes pensarán que este problema es
muy abrumador y estarán pensando dónde
está la solución
una parte de la solución está en manos
del gobierno pero no podemos quedarnos
esperando este problema de la corrupción
y cómo afecta a las mujeres
es tan grande que no debemos de dejarle
la responsabilidad única a los gobiernos
nosotros los ciudadanos y las mujeres
tenemos un papel fundamental para luchar
contra la corrupción y sus efectos en
nosotras
sin embargo algunos datos de cómo las
mujeres perciben la corrupción y cómo
luchar contra ella son preocupantes
las mujeres pensamos que somos ignoradas
al momento de denunciar actos de
corrupción
las mujeres también somos más proclives
a pensar que una vez denunciado los
actos de corrupción no se tomarán las
medidas necesarias por parte de las
autoridades
las mujeres también somos más proclives
a pensar que los ciudadanos comunes no
tenemos una influencia decisiva para
combatir la corrupción
y esto tiene que cambiarse porque los
ciudadanos comunes y las mujeres tenemos
un poder y una influencia decisiva para
combatir la corrupción
podemos exigir métodos de denuncia
sensibles al género para que menos
mujeres se sientan frustradas al momento
de denunciar
el poder de la denuncia tiene un efecto
multiplicador porque
en la primera denuncia una mujer se
genera una espiral en donde las demás se
animan a denunciar y así ver un impacto
colectivo de sus denuncias
la corrupción no es genética es un virus
y como tal puede ser prevenido con
vacunas eficientes y puede ser combatida
con medicamentos adecuados
la corrupción es una cadena y es
contagiosa y al ser un virus puede
juntar de diferentes formas para
hacernos daño pero nosotros las mujeres
podemos frenar la cadena de contagios si
ponemos distancia de los sobornos
si desarrollamos una memoria histórica y
colectiva para mandar a la congeladora a
todos los funcionarios y políticos
públicos que solapan la trata de mujeres
de aquellos que desvían recursos de
programas sociales que benefician a las
mujeres de aquellos que hacen caso omiso
a los feminicidios porque cabe mencionar
que la convención de naciones unidas
contra la corrupción señala que si
existe la corrupción por omisión
y por último quiero hacer un llamado a
todas
para unir la importancia de tratar este
tema y que de esta manera se generen las
acciones que dejen una huella violeta de
la no violencia hacia la mujer y un azul
de la no corrupción y frenar la cadena y
la epidemia de la corrupción y cómo
afecta a las mujeres
[Aplausos]
[Música]